but first up he's a neuroscientist and
author and host of the waking up podcast
my friend Sam Harris is over
[Applause]
nor are you my friend okay that's a good
sign they like you yes well yeah in a
minute
so I thought it was time we had a talk
because I knew early on in Trump's
administration he would do something
stupid about Muslims yes and he did I
think we both agree his ban I've always
said it's stupid it's counterproductive
it's on American but let's get that
right out of the way first that we both
think this is a dumb idea the Muslim ban
right yeah he is first of all Trump is
like Chauncey Gardner's evil twin I mean
he's if he does something right on this
issue it'll be like yeah yeah so and the
ban itself is just the sort of idea
you'd think he would come up with and
and press enthusiastically it's a
terrible idea even if you're only
concerned in security right and that's
not our only concern I hope we get to
that topic but I mean we have to win a
war of ideas with the Muslim world and
we need allies right and we've got
immigrants which about ideas yeah and we
want yes yeah the ideas cross borders I
mean the immigration is just one part of
this problem but we should be desperate
to have moderate Muslims in this society
we want moderate Muslims we want and
ones who speak out I thought it was
great when London elected a Muslim mayor
because when you elect someone mayor
then they have to say out loud our
Western values and he has he doesn't
even like it when women wear cover their
face yeah and when you view this as a
war of idea if you see that we need to
empower the actual Reformers in the
Muslim world to rights and the way to do
that is not to put a blanket ban because
you never know what is in someone's mind
do you remember this just last year the
Strasbourg fell that they broke up and
yes we hold okay I remember the headline
in the New York Times few days after
said terror suspects led mainstream
lives unsettling France right because
you don't know what they were saying
they're not they don't have beards the
guy with the ears he ran the grocery
sold liquor right was not scowling he
was smiling at the joke
you don't know what is in people's minds
yeah but
only I mean all these people are related
to other people right so only secular
liberal and former Muslims frankly can
can police this for us and this is a war
of ideas it's civil war of ideas that
has to happen within the Muslim
community and we have to help them win
it but we don't do that by by putting up
a blanket ban against Muslims and you've
had people on your show which are
exactly the sort of people we want
empowered like Oz or no money and ayaan
Hirsi Ali and my colleague Maajid Nawaz
Raheel and thinkyeah Raheel Raza Hill
Rosa I mean the reason why you should
view this is a war of ideas and be at
least hopeful but could potentially
hopeful about it is that Minds change I
mean soso demage it you who has been on
your show he was a former extremist he
spent four years in Egyptian prison for
his nefarious activities he's now as
reasonable and ethical a person as
you're ever going to meet and in that
and and yet he's now demonized by some
subset of the Muslim community and the
left as an Uncle Tom right right this is
ended so this is that's the kind of
thing that only empowers Trump and I
think art yes right I mean you talked
about in your last blog the fact that
odds were no money who's been on our
show and who I think is exactly what
you're talking about the kind of person
we want to empower he said she voted for
Trump yeah a liberal you doesn't like
him but she feels like it for the issue
that matters to her you're empowering
the wrong people you're the ones who are
oppressing me liberals that's where they
go and I think what we're trying to say
is we're trying to find ways to to
disempower Donald Trump and the left is
often not helping yeah well exactly to
take Oscars case you know in the
immediate aftermath of Orlando we have
Clinton talking about gun control only
and then then admonishing the whole
country not to be racist right now you
can't say that jihadism has no
relationship to Islam right and so it's
people like Ezra who were fed up with
this and there are millions of them said
it was just too galling to see in the
president you know he's been lying for
eight years about this now it's not to
say he hasn't been flying over oh yeah
but you know he's presumably he's been
he's not been bombing the Amish right so
he knows that it has some relationship
to Islam yeah he said in his final
address he said we've taken out tens or
ten thousand terrorists and I'm sure
most of them are all if not all of them
were ones who believed in the Koran that
seems like an awful lot if you're just
saying this is the fringe yeah yeah well
it's not just the fringe met that the
problem is it is the fringe is probably
just people who are actually violent
well it misses it was again the last
time we were here and this is where you
know we'll begin saying things that that
will piss off people and it's Batman but
here here call us a racist but yes it's
so they're they're they're jihadists who
will use violence immediately to and who
we're expecting to get into paradise
when they blow themselves up on an
airplane and in size matters I mean
there are entire terrorist armies Isis
yeah obviously I'll go Haram al Qaeda I
mean this just doesn't people talk about
the KKK like it's an equivalent the KKK
is not that that isn't your genuine
fringe phenomenon but when you take
jihadis and Islamists who who want
Sharia law they just want to use the
levers of a state together they're not
they're not committing violence
immediately and then you just have a
larger subset of conservative Muslims
who while they know that may not have
any alliance with jihadist they still
have attitudes around free speech and
the rights of women and the rights of
gays that are deeply at odds with our
own and we have to win a war of ideas
with these people this is not a we don't
fly drones to solve this this problem
and so this is why we need to empower
real reformers I know you were having a
bit of a Twitter spat sometimes with
this woman Linda Sarsour mouthing that
right yeah yeah okay she was at them
she was at the March and you know you've
mentioned that she tweets things like
sort of semi supportive of Saudi Arabia
saying because they give women
maternity leave more than we do yeah
they have some well this is the problem
so the the left has allied itself with
Islamists and closet Islamist and she's
none too closeted but she's a hijab' and
and and the hijab was promoted as as one
of the empowering symbols of feminism
for this march right and she's one of
the organizer sensible burka know the
burger we have showed the picture of the
burqa it seems like no that's this this
is what I want liberals to understand
that like there are some countries I
think French has banned this I'm not
sure banning I think that's not the
right approach is to tell anybody how
they can dress but also stop saying
that's normal
well that's not normal it's yeah if you
think that's normal you are so part of
the problem there is a human being in
there yeah it might want to ogle the Sun
on their face or make eye contact or
register a smile and most are not there
voluntarily that's the thing I mean
you're not for banning we should be able
to be able to wear whatever costume you
want but the subset of people who are
wearing these things purely because they
want to without being coerced by their
community right without without being
having a level of massage brainwashed
from salaries I mean no one wants to be
that and also I mean why are they
covering women like that because
otherwise men might get aroused right so
they're blaming the women for the men's
horniness I mean
if you were I mean you couldn't create
in a lab a idea that should be more
opposed by liberals then we covered the
women and blame them if men get horny
and we have one of this woman you
mentioned Linda Sarsour she's she's one
of the organizers organizing the women's
March she has people like Bernie Tweedy
and I stand I marched with Linda right
but she's someone who has gone after
ayaan Hirsi Ali who's a real feminist
hero and she's tweeted absolutely
defamatory things at her like she
doesn't deserve her vagina she deserves
an ass-whipping a meat eater this is she
does see a crack right why why is it
that liberals here seem to just really
want to from a gut level jumped
immediately always to we're just as bad
because we've been had we've done a lot
of bad things but on this issue
especially right now at this point in
history not every culture is equally bad
what is what is that is that just fell
out loathing well there are two things I
mean so I mean one just let's take that
claim you know take our take our quirky
religions right if the Scientologists
were practicing suicide bombings in
dozens of countries right if they were
killing people for drawing pictures of l
ron Hubbard right right you know Tom Tom
Cruise would have more to answer for
than he does right and he's got a fair
amount and support if the Mormons were
trying to kill Trey Parker in that stone
over there Broadway play okay would lose
our patience for Mormonism right so so
it's a massive double standard here but
this is this is the needle we have to
thread and this is the problem you and I
have been getting into for 15 years we
have to on the one hand acknowledge that
there are valid criticisms of misuses of
American power and colonialism and we
want to help refugees right want to
defeat these people in Syria are the
unluckiest people in the world right and
if they don't pose a security concern we
should welcome them into our society
right we don't want to look at the
Statue of Liberty and think
but but also you're not automatically a
racist if you have concerns about a
symbolism actually because you have the
ideas that we're talking about there are
sometimes assimilation problems I don't
think we have a lot of that in America
because but but because we've been lucky
with these two oceans right and so we
have to acknowledge that never a
classifier we don't want to have it's
America people if a Muslim here in
America wants to take off the thing she
can yeah and she's she can do that
without fear of someone beating her for
it
I mean if someone wants to come out of
the closet here in America if someone
wants to marry a non-muslim these are
not options available to vast amounts of
Muslims in the world so let's address
the question that they're they're saying
now who hate us which is you paint with
too broad a brush because we mentioned
some of these things right and let's
just we don't I don't think we paint
with a brush it's need to tell we're
painting with statistics right I mean
like you're talking about 43 percent of
this and 78 percent on any specific
question these numbers can move around
but the numbers are never consoling
right when you ask a Muslim Xin Roque
what do you want to live under Sharia
law right or whether whether the Danish
cartoonist should be imprisoned right
you don't get to tiny numbers you would
hope to get right and that's a problem
that we have to speak honestly about and
just as you just said you don't have to
be a fascist or a racist or even a
trumpian to not want to import people
into your society who think cartoons
should be killed for drawing the profit
right that's a totally rational thing
not to want and the left has been
demonizing anyone who will talk about
this right and I would say to you I
finally you know asking what is the
proper liberal response and I think it
begins with yes understanding that we
are never going to defeat terrorism if
we don't reform Islam yeah and we are
not going to reform Islam if we can't
talk about it and if Muslims can't talk
about and Muslims can't if we don't
encourage empower and
and glides Muslims to talk honestly
about this yes okay thank you Sam I
appreciate you coming here giving us the
real deal as always then there is
everybody